Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Luft raus, Log Roll
und dann rübernehmen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Tut da etwas weh, wenn man drückt?
Als Notfallmedizinerin
muss man sich entscheiden.
Es kann falsch sein
und man muss revidieren,
aber man muss entscheiden.
Er hat eine ziemliche Verletzung.
Vielleicht steht der Knochen raus.
Wenn Sie was brauchen, drücken Sie.
Dann kommen wir.
Dass er nicht immer
die gleiche Antwort gibt,
kann darauf hindeuten,
dass er eine Hirnerschütterung hat.
Was ist eigentlich passiert?
- Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Abstrich holen.
Viel Stress
und ständig gefasst sein auf alles:
Alltag in der Notfallstation.
Zwischen Banalität und Sterben
ist alles möglich.
Wie schaffen das die Menschen,
die da arbeiten?
Schichtbeginn
für Pflegefachmann Christian Tek.
Es ist 16 Uhr.
Ja.
Wir begleiten ihn
in die Notfallstation
des Universitätsspitals Zürich.
Auch sie hat heute Spätschicht:
- Sali zusammen.
Oberärztin Aline Herzog.
Wir können
einen sehr ruhigen Notfall haben
und in einer Stunde
explodiert alles,
fliegt einem alles um die Ohren.
Darum: bereit sein.
Wollen wir hier Übergabe machen oder
drüben? Machen wir schnell hier.
Nebenan bei der Pflege
verschafft sich auch Christian Tek
einen Überblick.
Doch das Prozedere wird unterbrochen.
Ich muss euch schnell stören.
- Ja.
Es kommt eine Sanität,
etwa um fünf nach.
Ein Mann:
Treppensturz, Amnesie zum Ereignis.
Der Fall ist dringlich -
ein ganzes Team versammelt sich.
Ist das ...
- Ja.
In der Notfallstation des Unispitals
sind das viele Leute.
Denn am Lehrspital ist immer auch
auszubildendes Personal mit dabei.
Kann ich loslegen?
- Ja, du kannst loslegen.
Das ist Herr Bisacca, Jahrgang 44.
Herr Bisacca ging mit seiner Ehefrau
die Treppe hoch
und stürzte,
ohne Stolpersturz oder so.
Seine Frau konnte nicht sagen,
ob es eine Synkope war,
aber eine andere Erklärung
gab es auch nicht.
Er schlug unten rückwärts auf
und hat einen Zahnschaden.
Es sind zwei Schneidezähne
ausgebrochen. Wir haben sie dabei.
Wir waren nicht sicher,
ob das ein normaler Zahn war,
darum haben wir alles
in Milch eingelegt.
Es war alles relativ emotional.
Jetzt ist er so weit schmerzfrei
und neurologisch unauffällig.
Ist das gut für euch?
- Ja. Ist gut, danke.
Für die Sanität
ist der Fall abgeschlossen.
Die Notfallcrew übernimmt.
- Grüezi wohl.- Grüezi.
Herzog ist mein Name,
ich bin die Oberärztin.
Das ist meine Kollegin
und es sind noch mehr Leute da.
Ich bin Giovanni.
- Grüezi.
Wie geht es im Moment?
- Gut, mit so vielen Frauen.
Genau.
Tut jetzt etwas weh?
- Meine Schulter tut etwas weh.
Ja. Rückenweh?
- Nein.
Tut es weh,
wenn man da hinten drückt?
Nein.
- Gar nicht?
Können Sie den Kopf
nach links und rechts bewegen?
Sehr gut.
- Erste Entwarnung.
Die Oberärztin
übergibt an die Assistenzärztin
und den Pflegefachmann.
Macht ihr noch ein EKG wegen
der möglichen Synkope?- Ja.
Man weiss nicht genau,
warum es zum Sturz kam.
Er kann es nicht sagen,
der Frau ist nichts aufgefallen.
Bei Älteren muss man daran denken,
dass es eine Herzrhythmusstörung
gewesen sein könnte.
Wir müssen schauen,
was mit den Zähnen ist.
Aber er hat keine Schmerzen
bei der Halswirbelsäule. Alles gut.
Keine Rückenschmerzen,
er bewegt sich normal.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Tut es weh, wenn ich drücke?
Ich schaue mir die Nase an.
So.
Man muss empathisch sein, darf es
aber nicht zu nahe ranlassen.
Ich helfe weder dem Patienten
noch den Angehörigen,
wenn ich hochemotional werde
und alles ganz nah an mich ranlasse.
Ich brauche eine gewisse Empathie,
das ist klar. Die braucht es.
Aber es braucht auch
eine gewisse professionelle Distanz.
Das kommt auch mit der Erfahrung.
Aline Herzog ist 39 Jahre alt.
Habt ihr die Übergabe schon gemacht?
Nein, noch nicht.
- Okay.
Seit sechs Jahren arbeitet sie hier.
Jetzt sieht man,
dass jemand im Warteraum ist.
Ich schaue rein:
Was ist es und wie dringlich ist es?
Alle Fälle werden triagiert.
Was nicht dringlich ist, muss warten.
Corona hat den Notfall verändert.
Einen ersten Corona-Check
gibt's bereits draussen.
Wer COVID-Symptome hat,
wird speziell behandelt.
Darf ich kurz schauen?
- Ja, mach nur.
Jeder Patient, der COVID hat
oder den Verdacht darauf,
bedeutet automatisch
einen Mehraufwand.
(Frau) Ist gut?
- (Frau) Ja, perfekt.
Super, danke dir. Tschüss.
Sie schauen nach oben
und ich mache den Abstrich.
Okay, Sie schaffen das. Super.
COVID ist in der Notfallstation
Normalität geworden.
Man habe die Krankheit
in den Arbeitsablauf integriert,
sagt man uns.
Wir gehen
zu einer anderen Patientin,
bei der man anfangs dachte,
dass sie COVID haben könnte.
Es hat sich herausgestellt,
dass sie es nicht hat,
dementsprechend
ist die Isolation aufgehoben.
Grüezi miteinander.
- Grüezi.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Medikament,
damit Sie besser atmen können.
Man hat herausgefunden,
dass Sie ein bisschen Wasser
um die Lunge haben.
Der Test, den wir gemacht haben,
war negativ.
Es ist
ein ständiges Kommen und Gehen.
Für Laien ein Riesengewusel.
Der Platz scheint überall knapp.
Vitamin D, einmal in der Woche.
Das ist okay.
Eine grössere Pause
wird für Oberärztin Herzog
an diesem Abend nicht drinliegen.
Ich mag keinen getakteten,
geregelten Arbeitstag.
Ich finde es toll,
wenn man nie weiss,
was da jetzt kommt heute.
Diese Unruhe, die es geben kann,
finde ich toll.
Ich habe es gerne,
wenn es so richtig läuft.
Wir leben ein bisschen vom Stress.
Gut organisieren ist von Vorteil.
Schnelle Aufnahmefähigkeit,
das Wichtige rausfischen können,
und das als Erstes erledigen können,
auch wenn anderes noch ansteht.
Und ein grosses Nervenkostüm haben.
Wir desinfizieren es
und kleben, wenn es getrocknet ist.
Oberärztin Aline Herzog
überprüft eine Wundversorgung.
Ich finde, das ist super.
Der Herr hat einen Kerzenständer
auf den Kopf erhalten,
von einer anderen Person.
Assistenzärzte betreuen
und wenn nötig unterstützen -
das gehört auch zum Job
der Oberärztin.
Die Haare
musst du noch etwas hochziehen.
Die Wunde nicht zu fest spreizen.
Noch etwas zusammenpressen.
- Was ist denn eigentlich passiert?
Meine Freundin
hat mir einen Kerzenhalter aus Stein
auf den Kopf geschlagen.
War es das erste Mal?
Leider nicht.
Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Perfekt.
Ärger in Partnerschaft und Familie
kommt immer wieder vor.
Opfer von häuslicher Gewalt.
Es ist schwierig für uns,
damit umzugehen.
Aber es gibt Beratungsstellen.
Wir geben da
auch die Telefonnummern mit.
Wir im Notfall sehen den typischen
Spiegel der Gesellschaft.
Grüezi. Morf, ich bin der Oberarzt.
Dr. Walter ist der Assistenzarzt.
Wir lagern Sie jetzt mal um,
dann können Sie uns in Ruhe
erzählen, was Ihre Beschwerden sind.
Am Rücken
fühlen Sie es am stärksten, oder?
In der Bauchgegend -
links, rechts, Oberschenkel.
Haben Sie
einen möglichen Auslöser bemerkt?
Meine Vermutung ist Waschmittel.
- Waschmittel?
Ist das mehr ein Druckgefühl
oder ein Herzklopfen,
das Sie stört?
Er hat die Medikamente
wie verordnet genommen.
Aber das EKG ist verdächtig.
- Finde ich auch.
Ist jetzt besser? Ist alles okay?
Die Herzmarker sind nicht erhöht.
Über 45'000 Patienten pro Jahr
werden in der Notfallstation
des Unispitals Zürich behandelt.
Die Klinik
ist an der Kapazitätsgrenze.
Notfälle unter 16 Jahren
verweist man ans Kinderspital.
Der Rest landet hier.
Der Kollege von Aline Herzog,
Oberarzt Samuel Morf,
übernimmt einen dringlichen Fall:
eine junge, minderjährige Frau
aus der Psychiatrie.
Also, machen wir Rapport?
- Wir haben noch kein Bett.
Sie öffnet schon die Augen,
siehst du? Ein gutes Zeichen.
Also, das ist ...
17-jährig.
Sie ist stationär im KJPD.
Sie hat heute mit einer Kollegin
je eine Flasche Chardonnay geext,
daraufhin hat sie einiges erbrochen
und ihre Psychiaterin
hat dann uns alarmiert.
Suizidversuch
vor ca. zwei, drei Monaten.
Die junge Frau
mit starker Alkoholindikation
wird an diesem Abend um Mitternacht
wieder in die Psychiatrie verlegt.
Eine Abklärung in der Notfallstation
dauert im Schnitt
dreieinhalb Stunden.
Nach viereinhalb Stunden
verlassen Patienten das Spital
oder werden
auf eine Bettenstation verlegt.
Alles ist durchgetaktet.
Oberärztin Aline Herzog
vergleicht ihre Rolle bei der Arbeit
mit ihrem Lieblingssport:
American Football.
Wenn man als Oberarzt Schicht hat,
ist man ein bisschen der Captain,
der das Team aufstellen muss.
Aber ich sehe mich nicht
als Vorgesetzte der Pflege.
Sie haben ihre Position,
in der sie auch besser sind als ich.
Wenn sie anderer Meinung sind,
wie sie das machen sollen,
haben sie auch recht.
Ich bin für die Taktik des Teams
zuständig
und wie man das aufstellt.
So, ist es gut gegangen?
Ging es gut, Herr Bisacca?
- Jawohl.
Gut, super.
Treppensturzpatient Giovanni Bisacca
ist fertig mit Röntgen.
Zurück ins Zimmer.
Diagnose: Nasenbeinfraktur.
Wie geht es Ihrem Kopf?
- Gut.
Kopf immer gut.
Atmen geht gut?
- Ja, ja.
Die unten ...
Es sind die oberen ...
Zwei sind ...
Die sind kaputt.
Aber atmen?
- Doch, das geht schon.
Gut.
Ist nicht immer ganz
einfach mit der Verständigung, oder?
Nein, das ist so.
Es ist nicht immer einfach.
Man lernt, den Schmerz
anders einzuschätzen,
als nur übers Verbale.
Man sieht durch körperliche Zeichen,
dass Schmerz als Hauptproblem
dahinterstecken könnte.
Dann fangen wir an, das zu behandeln
und schauen weiter.
Wahrscheinlich
ist er noch gestolpert.
Das ist die Chefin des Instituts
für Notfallmedizin, Dagmar Keller.
Seit sieben Jahren
leitet sie die Notfallstation.
Gelebte Fehlerkultur und eine
flache Hierarchie sind ihr wichtig.
Die Direktorin macht selbst
regelmässig Schichtbetrieb.
Die Eitelkeit hat keinen Platz
bei uns in der Notfallmedizin.
Du musst dir vorstellen:
Wir reanimieren gemeinsam
einen Patienten.
Da geht es ums Menschenleben
und nicht um Hierarchiestufen.
Darum sind wir jetzt
auch mit dir per Du?
Das ist bei uns Normalität.
Aber das ist natürlich
nicht überall im USZ so.
Häufig hat man strenge Hierarchien.
Ich habe mir
meinen Führungsstil früh angeeignet,
weil ich gesehen habe,
dass er viel konstruktiver ist,
wenn man im Team
und auch an der Front arbeitet.
Es ist kurz vor 20 Uhr: Die Rega
bringt einen dringlichen Patienten.
Wieder ein Treppensturz.
Das ist Herr Geeser, René,
79-jährig.
Er ist eine kurze Kellertreppe
runtergefallen,
acht bis neun Tritte, unbeobachtet.
Seine Ehefrau
hörte es rumpeln und ging zu ihm.
Traumacheck:
RQW okzipital auf der rechten Seite.
Sie hatten es bereits verbunden,
ca. 5 cm lang.
Sonst alles stabil
auf dem Transport.
Immobilisiert mit Vakuummatratze,
Halskragen.
Sehr gut.- Fragen?
- Von mir nicht.
Genau, Luft raus, Log Roll.
Und dann nach Log Roll
gleich rübernehmen.
Oberärztin Herzog und ihr Team
übernehmen.
Grüezi, Sie sind im Unispital.
Ja.
Alle bereit?
- Ja.- Eins, zwei, drei.
Tut das weh?
- Tut das weh, Herr Geeser?
Ja?
Und da unten?
- Unten tut es auch weh? Nein.
Und hier?
- Tut es da weh? Nein?
Jetzt?
- Ja.
Okay, ab oberer WBS.
Bereit? Eins, zwei, drei.
Eins, zwei, drei. Wir brauchen
noch ein Kissen für drunter.
Wir kommen oben rüber.
Gut.
So sieht es gut aus. Herr Geeser,
bleiben Sie ruhig liegen.
Ich gehe weg. Achtung, der Arm.
Das Bett laden.
Noch einmal ganz schnell. Ja.
Hat es noch Zähne drin?
- Nein. Keine Zähne.
Entschuldigung.
- Soll ich das Bett bremsen?
Tief atmen.
Können Sie tief ein- und ausatmen?
Es brummt auch ein wenig,
aber es ist seitengleich.
Es ist gut.
Tut da etwas weh, wenn man drückt?
Da?
Da auch nicht?
Die einzige Blutung, die ich sehe,
ist hinten am Kopf.
Er kann jetzt stabil bleiben,
sich aber auch relativ schnell
verschlechtern. Werden wir sehen.
Das könnte eine Lux ...
Sieht zwar ähnlich aus.
Es wird nass und kalt.
- Er ist hypertensiv.
Was haben wir für einen Druck?
168 zu 107.
Trotzdem ist es nicht symmetrisch,
scheint mir.
Er ist operiert, oder?
- Nein, nicht ganz. Ja.
Ist das Gespür hier gut?
Spüren Sie das,
wenn ich Sie hier streichle?
Ja? Gut.
Einmal die Finger so bewegen.
Auch gut.
Können Sie den Ellenbogen strecken?
Das kann er nicht so.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut machen Sie das.
Super.
- Tut es weh, wenn ich hier drücke?
Ich würde direkt durchfahren.
Er hat da vorne Hämatome.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob er hat.
Er hat keine erkennbare ...
- Es ist schon ziemlich blau.
Es ist ziemlich blau.
- Würgt es Sie?
Man könnte auf jeden Fall ...
- Hörgeräte?
Haben Sie Schwindel?
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Auch nicht. Kopfschmerzen?
Erst die zwei Röntgen
und dann CCT?- Ja.
Es gehört zum Job,
schnell zu entscheiden.
Basierend auf den Fakten,
die man im Moment hat.
Es gibt aber
auch noch das Bauchgefühl,
wie weit man geht oder auch nicht.
Das ist jetzt z.B.
eine ganz ähnliche Geschichte.
Wir hatten zweimal Treppensturz,
zweimal ähnliche Höhe.
Der erste Patient
kann uns sehr gut Auskunft geben,
und ist einfacher zu untersuchen.
Man sah, dass er mobil war, wie er
aufs andere Bett wechseln konnte.
Das ist jetzt ein Patient,
der noch Rückenschmerzen angibt ...
... immer wieder
die Augen schliesst,
und nicht ganz so adäquat reagiert.
Da geht man mit der Diagnostik
weiter als beim ersten.
Weil man nicht so gut einschätzen
kann, was alles kaputt ist.
Darum gibt es auch ein grösseres CT
als beim anderen Patienten.
Wissen Sie,
wo Sie jetzt hingekommen sind?
In Zürich.
Welche Nummer soll ich aufschreiben?
Die meiner Frau.
- Von Ihrer Frau?
Giovanni Bisacca, Treppensturzpatient
Nummer 1, geht es besser.
Nach wie vor holprig
ist die Verständigung
zwischen ihm
und Pflegefachmann Christian Tek.
Es ist alles weg. Ich weiss nicht.
Ich habe keine Batterie.
Ah so, für Sie. Okay.
Soll ich Ihnen das Handy aufladen?
Soll ich Ihr Handy aufladen?
-Aufladen, ja.
Soll ich?
- Können Sie das?
Ja, kann ich. Hier ist die Nummer.
Das ist für Sie.
Ja.
- Gut, okay.
Gut, okay.
- Alles klar.
Danke.
- Gerne.
Wir haben Huawei,
Samsung und iPhone.
Einfach in begrenzter Anzahl.
Es kann dann nicht jeder kommen.
Ist gut? Super.
Herr Geeser? Mein Name ist Herzog,
ich bin die Oberärztin.
Ich schaue mal rasch den Kopf an.
Der Zustand des zweiten Treppensturz-
patienten ist immer noch stabil.
Er ist etwas verlangsamt,
er gibt verzögert Antwort.
Wir müssen schauen, dass er keine
weiteren Blutungen im Kopf hat.
Um Klarheit zu schaffen,
werden die Blutwerte geprüft
und Patient René Geeser
wird ins Röntgen gebracht.
Damit du das schon weisst.
- Sehr gut.
Mittlerweile ist es kurz nach 20 Uhr.
Eine Spezialeinheit der Polizei
bringt einen jungen Mann
in die Notfallstation.
Seine Vorgeschichte ist lang:
U.a. mehrmals Zwangseinweisung.
Kurz: FU.
Polizeilich bekannter Patient,
hatte wegen psychischer
Ausnahmezustände schon mehrmals FU.
Heute Abend
hat er in einer Liegenschaft
von Hand Scheiben eingeschlagen.
Er hat rumrandaliert.
Es brauchte fünf Polizisten,
um ihn zu arretieren.
Er war
in einem ziemlichen Ausnahmezustand.
Er sagt, er habe
bei der Nachbarin aufgeräumt.
Er habe Ameisen und Spinnen und so
aufräumen müssen.
Höchst aggressiv. Das sind Spez,
keine normalen Streifenpolizisten.
Wenn es fünf von denen braucht,
ist die Post abgegangen.
Wirkt er auf dich psychotisch?
So mit Spinnen und Ameisen?
Ja ...
- Mit seinem Hintergrund?
Mit seinen Geschichten ... Er bringt
dieselben drei, vier Witze.
Ich möchte es nicht
als wahnhaft-psychotisch bezeichnen.
Es nähme mich wunder, was er bläst.
- Ist gut.
Wirklich.
Wie wollt ihr es? Wollt ihr umlagern
und die Fixierung lösen?
Er hat Hand- und Fussfesseln.
- Wenn er kooperativ ist, ja.
Wir holen von Beginn an
unseren Sicherheitsdienst dazu.
Ja, das würde ich.
Ich habe mit ihm abgemacht,
dass er kooperativ ist
und wir ihm helfen dürfen.
Dann sehen wir, was passiert.
Für den nächsten Augenblick
sind wir alle noch da.
Ist gut, prima.
Er hat zwölf Biere getrunken.
- Zwölf Biere?
Sali zusammen.
Im Moment ist er total kooperativ.
Aber auch vorbekannt
mit Fremdaggressivität.
Zieh doch noch schnell
ein Dormicum auf,
damit wir es in der Nähe hätten -
für den Fall.
Zur selben Zeit
holt der Pflegefachmann
einen nicht dringlichen Patienten ab.
Herr Senn, ich bin Christian Tek
von der Notfallpflege.
Wie geht es im Moment?
- Es geht.
Und es kam plötzlich?
- Ja.
Reinlaufen geht oder soll ich
einen Rollstuhl holen?- Nein.
Wie ist es vom Gespür her?
Keine Probleme.
Gefühl habe ich überall.
Simon Senn ist Diabetiker.
Wegen plötzlich anhaltender,
starker Beinschmerzen
ist er nach Feierabend
in den Notfall gekommen.
Okay, jetzt müssen Sie
rasch da Platz nehmen,
weil es drinnen voll ist.
Sie dürfen Ihre Sachen
alle da hinlegen.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Hemd, damit wir
Sie richtig untersuchen können.
Vielleicht sieht man ja etwas.
Ich komme gleich zu Ihnen.
Vielen Dank.
Die Spezialeinheit der Polizei
verabschiedet sich.
So, jetzt haben wir
nicht mehr so viele Leute.
Könntet ihr uns für ihn
Fenta aufziehen?
Er hat eine ziemliche Verletzung.
Nicht sicher,
ob nicht der Knochen raussteht.
* Wimmern *
Tut mir leid.
Ja, ich habe es gesehen.
Das ist Glas oder
irgendein Fremdkörper, glaube ich.
Einmal das Knie
hoch zur Nase ziehen.
Fest! Gas geben!
Gut. Die Kraft haben Sie, oder?
Es ist wirklich nur Schmerz?
Der Assistenzarzt untersucht
Diabetikerpatient Simon Senn.
Na gut, dann nimmt der Kollege
schnell Blut ab,
wir bestimmen ein paar Werte
und dann schauen wir.
Danke.
Der Kollege hat es versprochen:
Es gibt eine Blutentnahme.
Ich mache eine Infusion, dann
kann ich ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Ich habe noch nichts in der Hand,
um zu stechen.- Entschuldigung?
Ich habe noch nichts in der Hand.
- Ich will nicht hinschauen.
Soll ich stechen oder soll ich
Ihnen Bescheid geben?- Machen.
Okay.
Eins, zwei, Hosenbein.
Lässt du mich schnell raus?
Vielen Dank.
Anja, pass auf,
wenn du da vorne stehst!
Du bist das Hindernis.
Wenn etwas ist und die Leute
rausmüssen, bist du im Weg.
Nicht böse gemeint,
aber ich nehme dich einfach so raus.
Die medizinischen Dinge
sind wir uns gewohnt.
Das können wir immer regeln.
Aber ein Aggressionsereignis
ist für uns
auch immer eine Ausnahmesituation.
Man muss aufpassen,
dass man nicht dazwischensteht,
dass es einen nicht selbst erwischt.
Ist weiterhin gut?
- Ja.
Wir müssen noch ins Röntgen.
Ich wäre froh, wenn ihr mitkommt.
Wir machen ein Röntgenbild
und dann PCH, also ...
PCH, genau.
Das hier?
- Nein.
Diabetikerpatient Senn
wird jetzt auch noch
von Oberarzt Samuel Morf untersucht.
Ich will ja nicht,
dass man etwas findet.
Aber es wäre schon schön,
wenn man wüsste, woran es liegt.
Das fände ich gut.
Dass man sich selbst
so verletzen kann, ist heftig.
Aber unter Alkohol passiert einiges.
Da merkt man halt,
dass das Schmerzempfinden
nicht dasselbe ist wie ohne.
Die Sensibilität
ist intakt bei diesem Zweier ...
Beim aggressiven Patienten
muss eine Sehne operiert werden.
In dem Zustand
traue ich mich noch nicht,
den in die Wundversorgung zu nehmen.
Ich würde erst mal
Gewehr bei Fuss abwarten,
bis er ausgenüchtert
und zugänglicher ist.
Und bis der Psychiater hier war.
- Genau.
Das wird bei ihm
noch einmal ein Knackpunkt werden.
Gewalttätige Patienten -
damit hat auch Pflegefachmann
Christian Tek Erfahrung.
Es kann passieren,
weil sie alkoholisiert kommen,
den Prozess nicht verstehen
oder wegen anderer Drogen.
Es kann aber auch schlichtweg sein,
dass jemand lange warten muss
und nicht sieht, welche Prozesse
hier drinnen ablaufen.
Ich meine, ich sitze auch hier
und warte auf ein Bett.
Wenn jemand draussen wartet,
weiss er ja nicht,
was hinter der Türe vor sich geht.
So, bitte schön.
Die Wunden von Treppensturzpatient 1,
Giovanni Bisacca, sind versorgt.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Besser.
Besser.
- Also, ich nehme Sie zurück.
Jetzt gehen wir noch zu ...
- Wohin?
Wo bringen Sie mich hin?
- Wir gehen zurück ins Zimmer.
Ins Zimmer?
- Yes.
Jetzt können Sie bald - Achtung! -
auf die Abteilung.
Da sind wir wieder.
Bevor ich es vergesse,
hole ich noch Ihr Handy.
Sehr gerne.
Darf ich Sie fragen,
wie die Leute hier sind?
Die Leute sind bis jetzt gut.
Sie sind alle freundlich.
Sie machen ihre Arbeit.
Ich bin zufrieden bis jetzt.
Der Psychiater ist da.
Er soll den Patienten
mit Aggressionspotenzial einschätzen.
Also, er will
nicht so richtig mit mir sprechen.
Wollte er wahrscheinlich
mit euch auch nicht?
Ah, zu Anna hat er
ein gutes Verhältnis.
Ganz nüchtern ist er noch nicht.
- Nein.
Woher haben wir diese Info,
dass er FU hatte?
Von der Polizei.
Okay. Man hat kein gutes Gefühl,
ihn so zu entlassen.
V.a. mit dem massiven
Aggressionsereignis.
Mit vier Promille würde ich sagen,
dass er so besoffen war,
dass er nicht mehr urteilsfähig war,
aber 1,6 finde ich ...
Bevor wir ihn irgendwo einweisen,
muss man das wissen, oder?
Dann würden wir
vorher die Polizei rufen.
Wir würden nicht warten,
bis er den Notfall kleinschlägt.
Richtig. Danke vielmals.
- Planänderung:
Der Patient bleibt über Nacht
doch nicht in der Notfallstation.
Ein Hin und Her haben wir häufig.
Es ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür,
dass wir manchmal mit
vielen Konsiliarärzten zu tun haben.
Bei diesem Patienten
mit der plastischen Chirurgie,
Handchirurgie
und mit dem Psychiater.
Dann mischt sich die Polizei ein,
es braucht den Sicherheitsdienst ...
Wir haben ganz viele Leute,
die involviert sind.
Der Patient wird die Nacht
in der Psychiatrie verbringen.
Wie ist eigentlich
die Burn-out-Quote?
Bei uns relativ tief.
Ich glaube,
das hängt auch vom Umfeld ab,
also wie man es miteinander hat.
Der Job ist relativ befriedigend.
Er ist zwar anstrengend, aber
vielleicht ist ein ruhigerer Job,
der nicht so viel Sinn macht,
Burn-out-gefährdeter.
Jetzt kommt
so eine Schiene von da drauf.
Die ist am Anfang warm.
Die ist nur für hier unten und hier.
Es ist wie ein Gips. Ähnlich.
- Ah, wie ein Gips.
Und wie lange bleibt das?
- Bis morgen sicher.
So.
- Wie ein Gips.
Ähnlich, ganz genau.
Locker lassen.
- Mache ich doch.
Nein, nein. Ich merke das.
So. Gut.
Jetzt muss ich noch wissen:
Welche dieser Farben?
Blau.
- Blau?
Jawohl.
Hellblau haben Sie?
- Nein, leider nicht.
Hellblau ist schöner.
- Ist es schöner? Okay.
Ja. Umbria.
Das ist hellblau?
- Ja.
Florenz ist doch lila.
- Wie?
Florenz, Fiorentina.
- Da bin ich kein ...
Nein, wir in Italien ...
Italien ist blau.
Aha.
- Italien ist blau.
Geht es bei Ihnen?
Oberärztin Herzog bei
Treppensturzpatient 2, René Geeser.
Aber es blutet
wenigstens nicht mehr fest.
Da kann man ja nicht telefonieren?
Wollen Sie Ihre Frau anrufen?
Ja, das schaffen wir.
Geht es Ihnen besser?
- Ja, es geht gut.
Geht es gut? Super.
Die Schulter ist einfach kaputt.
Das Schlüsselbein ist
nicht mehr dort, wo es sein sollte.
Und eine Rippe ist angeknackst.
Das merke ich nicht.
Die Schulter spüre ich.
Ja, das glaube ich Ihnen.
Ich glaube, es war Glück im Unglück.
Über eine Woche wird René Geeser
noch im Spital bleiben müssen.
Dann kann er nach Hause.
So, Herr Senn,
Sie dürfen nach Hause.
Der Kollege
von der ärztlichen Seite
macht noch die Papiere für Sie
bereit, dann dürfen Sie gehen.
Sind die Schmerzen besser geworden?
- Ja, jetzt ist gut.
Schönen Abend.
- Ihnen auch.
Diabetiker Simon Senn hat sich
eine klare Diagnose gewünscht.
Bei ihm heisst es nun:
muskulär bedingte Beinbeschwerden.
So, jetzt haben wir es geschafft
- Happy End?
Happy End, für uns ist heute fertig.
Xenia, ist gut für dich?
Ja, ist gut.
- Tschau, ruhige Nacht.
Tschüss zusammen.
- Tschüss.
Tschau, Marius, ruhige Nacht.
Wir haben ein gutes Team,
man kann schwierige Fälle
auch mal miteinander besprechen.
Das hilft relativ viel.
Und auch privat, dass man einen
verständnisvollen Partner hat,
wie ich das habe,
der die Notfallmedizin auch kennt.
Oder eine Familie, die hinter einem
steht. Das ist schon wichtig.
Dass man gewisse Geschichten
mit der Freundin bespricht,
die selber in der Pflege tätig ist,
und das nachvollziehen kann.
Mit jemandem darüber zu reden,
der den Job nicht kennt,
hat manchmal
gewisse Schwierigkeiten.
Ich rufe jetzt die Abteilung an,
gebe Bescheid,
und dann gehen Sie nach oben.
Ist das gut? Dann kommen Sie
in ein richtiges Zimmer.
Das dauert noch ca. 20 Min.
Plus minus.
Letzte Arbeitshandlung
vor Schichtende.
Ist gut?
Fünf Tage wird Treppensturzpatient
Giovanni Bisacca
noch im Spital bleiben müssen,
zur Überwachung
seines Schädelhirntraumas.
Aline Herzog und Christian Tek
sagen beide:
Meist nehme man die Geschichten
vom Notfall nicht mit heim.
Denn: Die Behandlungen
seien für sie abgeschlossen.
Die nächste Schicht übernimmt.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021